the answer is Android permission not
internet I'll show you now where it's
located in the code under the main
folder open up the androidmanifest.xml
file within the Android manifest file we
declare users permission with the name
of the permission we verify that the
data returned is correct by adding a
verbose log statement for printing out
the forecast JSON string this is in the
fetchweathertask we can verify that it's
going to show up in the logs for this
example I'm going to use the command
line these are the real-time logs and
then if I hit refresh then I see the
weather data here super bowls log and
this is our log tag fetchweathertask
here's the forecast JSON string and this
is all the output from the server